Hi, I'm Jordan DeFrank from Family Fun,...
...here to show you how to make marshmallow Pilgrim hat treats.
For this recipe, you'll need:...
...chocolate striped shortbread cookies, a 12-ounce package of chocolate chips,...
...marshmallows, skewers, white fruit chew and yellow decorator's frosting.
You can find the complete recipe at familyfunmag.com.
Set the chocolate striped cookies stripes down on a wax paper-covered tray,...
...spacing them well apart.
Melt the chocolate chips in a microwave or double boiler.
One at a time, stick a skewer into a marshmallow.
Dip the marshmallow into the melted chocolate and promptly center it atop a cookie.
Set the hats in the refrigerator until the chocolate sets.
Using scissors, cut a quarter-inch strip of white fruit chew and wrap it around the hat.
Pipe a yellow decorator's frosting buckle on the front of each hat.
Crunchy and sweet, these marshmallow Pilgrim hat treats ...
...are a great way to cap a Thanksgiving classroom party.